Former President Donald Trump and Florida
Governor Ron
DeSantis are taking veiled
swipes at one another
as the race for the Republican
presidential nomination heats up.
This as other potential GOP
hopefuls edge
closer to campaigns of their own.
CNN's Kristen Holmes has the latest.
Former President Donald Trump and Florida
Governor Ron
DeSantis
previewing a 2024 primary showdown.
For those who have been wronged
and betrayed, I am your retribution.
I am your retribution.
So in Florida, we say very clearly
we will never, ever surrender
to the woke mob.
Our state is where Woke goes to die.
In a grievance
laden speech at the Conservative
Political Action Conference.
Trump blasted
the Republican establishment.
We are never going back to the party
of Paul Ryan, Karl Rove and Jeb Bush
on his way
to winning a resounding victory
in the conference's
unscientific straw poll,
demonstrating the former
president's enduring support
with some of the party's base
while not naming DeSantis.
Trump taking aim
at his potential
rivals past support
for reforming entitlement programs.
We're not going back to people
that want to destroy our great
Social Security system,
even some in our own party.
I wonder who that might be.
Hello, California.
Speaking at the Reagan Library
in California, DeSantis
seeming to jab at the tumult of the Trump
White House. Years and for years.
You didn't see our administration
leaking like a sieve.
You didn't see a lot of drama
or palace intrigue.
What you saw was surgical
precision execution
Day after day after day,
the dueling speeches
foreshadowing an expected
20, 24 collision
with both Trump and DeSantis
set to visit Iowa in the next week.
While Trump
remains a clear
frontrunner, he's
also facing fresh challenges,
including ongoing investigations
to his handling of documents
and his role in the attack.
On the U.S.
Capitol.
The former president telling reporters
this weekend he would not exit the race
even if he is indicted.
This as the 2024 field take shape
with some hopefuls backing away.
Worried a crowded contest
could benefit Trump.
I didn't want to have a pile up
of a bunch of people fighting.
The more of them
you have the less chance
you have for somebody rising up.
But not all 2024
contenders sharing that view
including former Arkansas
Governor Asa Hutchinson,
who is weighing a bid.
I actually think that more voices
right now in opposition
or providing an alternative
to Donald Trump
is the best thing
and the right direction.
And, Wolf, we are still very
early in this 2024 primary
and is expected to be a fairly crowded
Republican field.
But I am told that Donald Trump
and his team remain
laser focused on
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis.
They have been looking into
his background, his wife's background.
They've been watching old debate clips.
They have essentially been talking
to former allies and not to mention
that some of DeSantis,
former staffers and advisers
actually work for Trump and for the Trump
super PAC now.
So this is all setting up
what's expected
to be a very ugly
and very personal battle
between these two men.
It certainly will be lively.
Kristen Holmes, thank you very much.
Let's get some analysis
from our chief
political correspondent, Dana Bash.
And CNN political analyst
Maggie Haberman.
Dana, what are these
dueling speeches
tell you
about the clearly deepening divide
inside the Republican Party
and what this might mean
for the 20, 24 election
Well, what's interesting
about these two
contenders, one,
DeSantis, a potential contender
he hasn't formally announced, is that
it doesn't seem
as though those two really illustrate
what is a deep divide.
It's not as if
as if they're totally taking
from the same pool of voters,
but similar.
What DeSantis is clearly trying to do
is to appeal to Trump voters
who are kind of done with the chaos, done
with the legal troubles, done
with all of the
the tumult that we saw over four years.
In the Trump years
and definitely since then.
So the two of them are battling
kind of for similar voters
that happen to make up
at least that right now
the large
part of the Republican
primary electorate.
And then you have the Asa
Hutchinson ends,
the Chris new news
that Chris
Christie is the other potentials
who might have been kind of
in a similar lane to Larry Hogan.
And the question is,
and even Nikki Haley
the question is whether there is enough
of an electorate there to support
something that shows the divide.
You know, Maggie, it's
interesting that Trump
so far is avoiding
criticizing DeSantis by name.
Why is that?
And should we expect the overt jabs
to start flying soon?
Well, I would say he's
criticizing him by name
when he calls him Ron
to Sanctimonious
or Ron DeSantis,
which we've seen him
do on his social media feed.
And he's been road
testing other nicknames
although he claims otherwise falsely.
In general,
I think that he is trying not to elevate.
I think he is trying
not to put too much of a face
on him, Wolf,
because he is somebody DeSantis who
not every Trump voter knows,
who not everybody is familiar with.
And I think that he wants to keep that,
you know, him sort of at a remove.
I expect that is going to change.
And remember,
we are looking at a 90 day period
where we're going to see
a lot of Ron DeSantis
because he's doing this book tour
or some of them anyway.
And then we are going to know
exactly how many other people
are jumping into this field.
So a lot could change.
Dana, is anything
including various legal issues,
for example,
going to slow the former
president's momentum right now?
He has said he would not leave the
race even if he is indicted
Well, if you
define momentum as the support
he has from voters, you know, TBD,
it could.
If you define momentum
as his desire to run for president,
there's no indication
right now that the answer is yes,
that his own personal momentum
or his fervor for running
isn't going to change.
In fact,
Maggie can likely answer
this better than I.
But the more in trouble he is, the more
likely he is
to keep his political situation afloat
because he believe it believes it
benefits him not only legally,
but politically,
that the two actually oddly,
only for someone like him.
When I say this
kind of help
help one another in his various quests.
Yeah.
Let me let Maggie weigh in on this point.
Go ahead, Maggie.
Sure.
Wolf, look, I certainly
think he's going to use,
you know, the political
the excuse me, the legal cases
that he may be facing
in the coming months
as a cudgel in his campaign.
I don't know how successful
that's going to be.
There's on the one
hand, a real danger about it,
because we've already seen the effect
that Donald Trump
can have on his supporters
with his words and his claims
that he is being
mistreated in some way or being,
you know,
denied his due or dealt with unfairly.
And that was January
six, 2021 at the Capitol.
On the other hand,
we saw last year after the raid at Mar
a Lago,
after the FBI search of his home
and private club,
Republicans rallied briefly.
And then the more facts came out,
it started to erode the support for him.
So we'll see what happens
We shall see, indeed.
Maggie Haberman, Dana
Bash, guys, thank you.